hi guys it's me again so just as a new
lot course creature so it seems pretty
appropriate for halloween I haven't
actually seen anything of it yet but
don't starve is a pretty cool game in
itself there is one thing I should warn
you i am a massive massive [ __ ] love
horror games forget absolutely [ __ ]
terrified by them but I've got
housemates so I can't scream my head off
like I would do back at home but we'll
see i'll probably have to restrain them
with my hands so yeah we'll see i guess
pitts creek
okay Oh what was that sound okay
flashlight oh I don't have back I don't
have a mouse can't wait here anymore i'm
going to call the helicopter not see
thank you thirty percent okay okay doke
up one badge sweet
stay
I like it smart 3d I like the grass okay
Hospital helipad I mattered family okay
cool super don't look at it okay it kind
of reminds me of splendor which isn't a
good thing and isolated always good okay
it's like a peanut yeah the path
ah
something must our camp last night
things getting weird I haven't seen the
Brazilian coupled in death so cold it is
generated walk on the peanut this week
now oh [ __ ] I totally forgot you have to
like light bias or something I hear of
this I water fast it and it's jacket no
goin looking further busy getting scared
let's get out of here I shy then but I
have the guide it's my library card
I say let's go
Jesus
ha
oh no I didn't look around I can't build
batteries fire pit
let did thing oh god why did you do that
I told what is this I'm much preferring
this I'm going in a circle I'm going in
a circle okay
I got it okay Eddie bad blood
fat man so the one of the sicilian
couples
once it's 4.46 for was its Oliver open
ease back Russell Hayes why look Dylan
Cummings it's clever
don't get it okay don't flip
just like how fast you can run
ok oh we found out okay
[ __ ]
ah
duffel bag
I got a bad
once these are lit that helicopter came
and can how do i light it oh sweet so I
found it nice oh please do things okay
from 0
for anybody
Allah
that was good that was our you take it
oh one more now sucks pretty though
frost Rory literally these boots so my
house key is outside so i will say thank
you for watching